I have no family history of cancer, but since I'm under 50 and have my lateral breast cancer,
they suggest I do genetic testing. Is it information worth having or not?
So the genetic testing that the oncology department is going to do is going to be for some very
specific genes that can have tendencies to run into family that could be at cause of cancer.
Now they can do some genes that we can't do. Now there are genes that they will typically run
when they do that study. And what are the bronchagines? So this person says I was always under
the impression that even if they found the bronchagines or other mutations, that should not really
change my treatment decisions. Or would it be helpful to know if there are any other cancer related
genes lurking in my DNA? My answer to this is if they're willing to run this test and your
insurance is going to cover it by all means, I'd say go for it. Yes, run the gene, run the test.
Now when we we also look in our genetic profile, we look at your bronchagines too. Now there are
bronchagines, all your genes have family of genes. So your bronchagines are a family of genes.
There's actually about around 100 different bronchagines. Now there's really only when they do a test
for you, when the oncologist does a test, they're really looking at about three or four of the bronchagines.
Because those are have been tied to the most significant ones that can lead to an inability to fight
cancer. So I just said your bronchagines are tumor suppressor genes. There are numerous
different families of tumor suppressor genes like the bronchagines that if you have mutations,
slash defects of those genes, those genes won't work as well. Why is that important? Because tumor
suppressor genes turn on when a cell goes into rapid replication and it turns on and it stimulates
apoptosis of the cell. So it can turn on and stimulate cell death so that that's one way that
God put in us to be able to fight against cancer. Because remember we've said, what are the struggles
with cancer? Is that cancer? Is your own cells? Something gets inside the cell, damages the DNA, causes
the DNA to go into rapid replication. What could it be? Could it be a toxin? Could be a mold toxin?
Could be a pesticide? Could be an herbicide? Could be a heavy metal? Could be a bacteria? Could
be a lime bacteria? Could be a fungus? Could be a virus? Something gets inside the cell and causes
the cell to go into rapid replication and then it replicates cells that are also equally dysfunctioning
in a state of rapid replication. That's what cancer is. Where that happens, you have lots of different
tumor suppressor genes. Right now there's known about 25 different families of tumor suppressor
genes that will turn on and help cause that cell to go to die. It's an internal stimulation of
in what's called an intrinsic apoptotic pathway. It causes that cell to die. If you have defects in those
genes, you can have a more difficult time killing cancer because that you're completely
reliant on the external pathway or the extrinsic apoptotic pathway. Something killing the cell from
the outside, your immune system, killing the cell from the outside. That's what we're trying to do
with the right machines. Stimulate in a viewed response on the cell to kill the cell from the
outside. Stimulated extrinsic apoptotic pathway. That's what we're trying to do with nutrition. That's
what you're trying to do with dietary, that's what you're trying to do with everything else to try
to do with chemotherapy. Stimulate that extrinsic pathway. Well, your body has this intrinsic pathway
through the tumor suppressor genes. But when we have defects on those genes, we have a more
difficult time killing cancer through that pathway. It doesn't cause cancer. If you have a
brachogy defect, does that cause cancer? That's not what tumor suppressor genes do. But if you do
get cancer, you'll have a more difficult time killing it simply because of that. But understand,
there's even more widely studied than the brachogynes. There are the P53 genes. There's the
K-ROS genes. There's tons of different gene families that I look at when I look at your genetics
and that's how I make different recommendations based upon that. But long story short, if they're really
doing that test for you, by all means, I'm all for testing. It's just a blood sample. Let them do it.